titute and I'll be chairing the session
today thank you all for being here is my
very great honor and pleasure to
introduce Robert dustman the current
director of the McGovern Institute and
the Donna Doris and on Berkey professor
in neuroscience so bob has really
conducted classic and foundational work
on attention throughout his career and
he continues to do so but he's also just
a tireless leader of the research here
at the McGovern Center playing a leading
role in the launch of for example the
hawk ten and Lisa yang Center for autism
research and the Poitras Center of
psychiatric research and they see
everyday the tireless work that he does
throughout the Institute in helping for
example push forward the generation of
new model systems for examining
psychiatric disorders and without
further ado I'll turn things over to Bob
and it's fitting that his talk tight
self which is an overview of current
research hope that McGovern Institute is
precision neuroscience a journey through
the McGovern Institute thanks Abby you
know many of us probably have an image
of Pat McGovern in our minds and I'll
tell you the image I have is not of Pat
up there it's always smiling down on us
but I act my image of Pat is really much
closer I would say looking over my
shoulder
now I imagine Pat really all the time
looking sort of judging like how are
things going and are you really like
making progress you know and the
trajectories that we had all agreed on
and I regard today is kind of a
five-year progress report to pet you're
going to be I'll be giving you an
overview of things that going on in the
McGovern Institute and then you're going
to be hearing some speakers from
McGovern Institute here at MIT and our
sister institutes in China and we'll see
what path thinks now I've heard Pat
Lorie found it the McGovern Institute
and I would say our mission statement is
kind of evolved in that of course it
it's as its based the understanding of
the brain and the mind and that's always
been the foundational work of the
McGovern Institute but I think it's a
that we have evolved and then borders
are formally endorsed a second part of
our mission which is to take when
possible that knowledge we develop about
the brain and apply it in ways that will
help people and I think Pat was always
really dedicated to this idea that
ultimately neuroscience is going to help
people primarily through health and
brain disorders but you imagine that
there would be a really widespread
impact on society and that's what we've
been trying to do now you heard Phil
sharp the founding director of the
McGovern Institute give an absolutely
marvelous account of the history and
development of the Institute and I would
say our philosophies that we follow
today really derive from those that that
Phil put in place and the most important
step that Phil took as director was
recruiting a group of existing MIT
faculty members to be the founding
faculty members
the McGovern Institute and they have
continued to be the core and guiding
influence of the McGovern Institute over
the years and Bob Nancy Emilio Martha
Tommy have just been a tremendous source
of of inspiration over the years and I
think one of the things that Phil
pointed out was the breadth of research
represented in the core faculty members
the breadth span from cellular like
Euler narrow science to systems the
cognitive neuroscience computational
neuroscience and I have to say that this
idea that Phil had was pretty
controversial at the time I think there
was a lot of thinking that the McGovern
Institute should pick you know a more
narrow range of neuroscience and and
just keep focused on that and I think
that Phil's insight was that the
neuroscience of the future was going to
depend on us understanding the brain of
mine at multiple levels and that has
guided the further development of our
faculty they span all these levels and
again it was although I think it was
controversial at the time these days
when I hear of new neuroscience
Institute's being established and
expanded and so on they're all following
this sort of model the multi-level with
people some people are sits at the
intersections of levels but certainly
everyone is communicating and across
levels and that that is what is going to
enable us to go from the mind and brain
down to an understanding that goes down
to the level of cells and the molecules
and genes in cells
so in just I'm just going to review
really a few of the highlights of work
over the years and I'm leaving out a
tremendous amount of stuff I acknowledge
that yeah it's it but I just want to
really give you a sense of the kinds of
things that we've been doing and I'm
going to adopt a theme that I'm actually
trying out on you and the theme is that
we can describe the what is taking place
in neuroscience is what I would call
precision neuroscience and I'll be
explaining what I mean by that and that
this development of precision
neuroscience is leading us to what I'll
argue is going to be precision
applications of neuroscience and those
include in health education and
technology and I'm going to give you
some examples of that as well
now I'll take is one example of why say
precision neuroscience at the level of
facial localization is taken from the
work of one of our junior faculty
members mark Cornett who goes in and
records from inside individual neurons
and not just individual neurons
individual pieces of neurons and is able
to uncover the nature of computations
that take place in cells now I say our
the standard thinking in the field has
been for many years that the important
computations of the brain take place at
the level of neural circuits lots of
cells interacting with each other but
one of the things I think that's really
exciting that Mark is discovering is
that many of these computations are
actually taking place within and you're
a neuron they actually carry out very
complex computations based on the
processing within all their dendrites
all those little the pieces of the cells
that you see there and and another thing
that he's done is by comparing neurons
across species most of his work is in
mice but he's now going into Nermin
Deron's he's taking brain tissue from
patients who have undergone brain
surgery at over at MGH and he rushes
this over here to the building and can
record from your human neurons and his
finding properties of cells which may
give Yurman neurons an even greater
level of complexity at the single neuron
level and this is his Markus beginning
to explain that to us no no another
example of what I would argue is the
increased spatial precision of
neurosciences from the work of ed Boyden
Minh his work in expansion microscopy
where he's able to take a piece of brain
tissue and we hope someday maybe whole
brains and expand them up so that when
they are examined microscopically we
really can see large volumes of the
brain imaged at unprecedented detail at
the level of all the synapses and
processing
of cells and now as Edie's is taking us
even a step further and is able to now
spatially localized a lot of even the
molecules and gene transcription factors
and so on within all these cells and
their cell parts
I think Ed's work is going to truly give
us the Google map of the brain down at
the level of the individual street
corners and signs and so on and this is
really going to be critical for
understanding how how all this works
I'll take another example from Ed's work
that comes from our increase temporal
resolution and our ability to study the
brain and that's of course Ed's work in
optogenetics which has absolutely
revolutionized neuroscience is one of
the cofounders of of optogenetics this
ability to genetically alter cells and
then stimulate cells with light
controlling them with millisecond
precision which is giving us this
ability to understand the operation of
neural circuits and even now we're
beginning to see the development of
clinical trials making use of
optogenetics in this way now I'm going
to jump levels here and talk about our
spatial precision and understanding the
brain really at a global level at the
level of the human brain the examples
from the work of Nancy kanwisher who
you'll be hearing about from later today
who is showing us in the area of
perception how very complex functions
such as the recognition of faces and
colors and scenes and so on are taking
place and functionally specific circuits
that are also functionally localized and
she's beginning to understand how these
circuits interact with other circuits
how they develop over in development in
both animals and people and I think that
this is giving us a sense of a the
general operating principle of the brain
which Nancy described
as the Swiss Army model of the brain
with specialized circus for specific
functions that is in contrast that I
think sort of the conventional view that
the brain is like a Pentium processor is
pretty much all the parts of doing the
same things it's running different
programs and really it's what's nancy's
work is showing us is that's really not
the case taking us up even to another
higher level of abstraction is the work
of Rebecca Saxe who's looking at the
functional localization of even more
complex cognitive functions in the human
brain and you'll be hearing from her
later today on she's looking at the
functional localization some very
processes like the theory of how other
people are thinking for example and how
this relates to social perception and
social cognition and now she's even
taking this to the development and
children how these concepts that are so
important to what it means to be a human
being how they develop in children
what's necessary for them to develop and
children to become to become adults
so as I mentioned you know I see this
this progress in precision neuroscience
is ultimately leading us to precision
applications in education health and and
technology and giving you an exit of the
of what this means at the level of
education is work of John Gabrieli
who is using brain imaging in humans to
understand childhood development and
childhood disorders such as dyslexia for
example now it turns out that dyslexia
is a very heterogeneous disorder there's
many different types of of dyslexia and
John is using brain imaging to sort of
dissect out what's going on in different
subgroups of kids with dyslexia and he's
actually even extending this beyond
dyslexia into trying to understand the
brain systems involved and say
distinguishing between good readers and
poor readers for example and he's even
identifying that some of these systems
are can be identified in children even
before they read based on the
connectivity of these areas and what I
think we're going to be looking forward
to in the future is the idea as the
early markers that predict that which
kids will have learning disabilities of
different types and that we will then be
divine designing interventions to
address those before the kids even begin
their formal instruction and I think
that that this is going to be true in
many aspects of early education as
identifying which kids will benefit the
most from different types of educational
experiences now is we're not going to be
giving brain scans to all of our
children as much as they need them but
but once we begin to understand the
neural systems it also allows us to
identities are like biomarkers is
behavioral markers that can be done much
easily and cheaply in children and get
them on sort of the right educational
path
I want to bring up another example of
what I see as leading to precision
education is a is a collaboration with
John Gabriela in some of our Chinese
colleagues here from Beijing Normal
University which was done in a Beijing
kindergarten and what we did in that
study was to test the effects of early
music education in comparison to extra
reading instruction in these
kindergarten kids and use EEG measures
to probe how these kids were processing
information and what we found was maybe
not so surprisingly was that the kids
who had the piano education became
better at distinguishing between tones
okay that sort of makes sense but also
they became better at distinguishing
between some of the sounds and words
that for example distinguishing
consonants which is really the
foundation of language development in
children and we know that in certain
types of dyslexia this is specifically
impaired and again our what our plan
would be is to identify which children
might benefit the most from this kind of
early music education and target them so
that then this again this gives them an
advantage in their early education and
and those studies will be getting
underway now is another example of what
I take as this facially precise
applications in health is the work of an
Graybill who you'll be hearing about
today and Graybiel has been identifying
with neuro recordings and anatomical
methods the neural specific neural
circuits that are important for example
in anxiety and affect is an valence
positive and negative advancement words
and punishments and so on and now having
identified these circuits she can then
target them and in collaboration with
our colleagues Bob Langer and Michael
CIMA she is developing these incredibly
small devices that can
both record neural activity record even
neurotransmitters like dopamine being
released in cells and then applying
minut amounts of drugs to just those
specific circuits and they are now in
this collaboration developing this ice
for use and Parkinson's for disease for
example and so what we what we're
looking forward to there's applications
targeting just those cells that are
involved in disorders and not
necessarily bathing the entire bodies
and pharmaceuticals another example of
imprecise applications of course is in
the field of genetics and throughout the
field of genetics what we're learning is
that medical categories that the
categories like that we use like bipolar
disorder schizophrenia autism depression
and so on then these are broad labels
but they actually encompass many
different biological disorders that have
different genetic signatures in autism
for example we know that there's a
variety of genetic mutations that
contribute to vulnerability to autism
and some of them have shared biology and
some of them may not and that means that
the therapies of the future are going to
have to address this specific disorder
that someone has and function who's
developed the revolutionary new tool
known as CRISPR is is that uses
developed this technology to develop
those treatments for specific
genetically defined disorders in both as
a research tool but also we're now
seeing increasingly even in clinical
trials using CRISPR related technologies
that are going after RNA editing in
adults for example and I think over the
over the next few years we'll be seeing
more and more clinical applications of
this technology
in a related way Fung is using these
CRISPR related methods to detect
disease-causing agents and detective
ulnar abilities to disease so for
example he can use and what is now is a
very inexpensive easy to apply
technology that can be used out in the
field it could use in developing
countries to detect and fetch infectious
agents like as Ebola Zika for example
and then and as well as disease-causing
mutations and cancer and mutations that
lead to vulnerabilities and I think this
kind of approach is going to have a big
impact on healthcare in the upcoming
years as well co-op being funky we'll be
hearing from later is taking these
CRISPR based technologies and using them
to develop better genetic models for
disease now of course the work and work
in mice has always been the foundation
of biology and neuroscience and will
certainly remain so but one of the
disappointments of the work in mice has
been that many treatments develop in
mice have not translated into
applications that can be used in people
and so what pain is developing advanced
primate models of these brain disorders
and we have as our first major project
that was done in collaboration with our
colleagues here from science engine
institute advanced technology we have a
paper at review under a major journal
reporting our first group of monkeys
with an autism related mutation shank
three and these monkeys show a variety
of behavioral abnormalities that
resemble a lot what is seen in this
particular form of autism they have
sleep disturbances they have they have
MRI signatures of brain connectivity
differences that's giving us new insight
and over the next few years what we
anticipate as are these genetic models
being developed both in China and here
in
tea will be used for both developing and
testing new therapeutics whether it's
drugs or whether it's genetic
technologies
I was you know I guess I used the wrong
slide yeah this problem with seeing from
every yards using the wrong slide for
talking about funks disease detection
technology so I've already given you
that so I want to turn to it lastly
another application of what we talked
about is the precise applications in
neuroscience and that is in the
development of Technology particularly
development of artificial intelligent
systems and these neural models which
then give us insight about how the brain
works and one of the leaders in this
field has been Tommy Poggio for example
he has developed artificial systems for
visual recognition and some of his
students have applied this this general
approach to developing collision
avoidance systems and self-driving cars
and so on
and Jim DeCarlo was taking this work
even a step further in developing these
artificial models which have properties
that resemble those of the neurons that
he records in the primate brain so for
example he will develop take these
models train them on massive databases
of images like you see the chairs here
and they learn to recognize these and
then he will find the models whose have
properties that resemble those of the
neurons that he studies and primates and
but of course the question that is often
raised by this kind of work is well but
what's the biological relevance of these
models I mean how do we know that this
artificially developed model actually
resembles how the brain actually does
these same computations so in recent
work he's done a really fantastic test
of this idea in that he has taken these
models that have developed these neural
properties that seemed to resemble those
that he finds in his recordings and he
said okay so if this is a really
biologically relevant model we should be
able to use the model to predict what
will happen if we show
oh the monkey and therefore these
neurons images that have they've never
seen before and we will predict the
neurons response from the model and and
so he'll take this for example the the
models prediction of the neural activity
caused by the cat and he can look at
this activity across the population this
that bar graph up top is just an
activity measure recorded across a group
of cells and one of the things he's
asked is well let's say that we want to
make one neuron in this population given
a more selective response and so it'll
respond more and its neighbors will
respond less can we use the model to
predict what would that image be and it
turns out that this image down here on
the right what seems like a bit of
nonsense but the network came up with
that and it predicted that if you were
to show the monkey that pattern it would
give you a more precise activation
pattern in the population and indeed
that's what he finds the the the the
actual population records resembles what
the model predicts suggesting that we're
on the right track now one of the other
I think think major insights that Pat
had was that these problems that we've
been talking about understanding the
brain and helping people with brain
disorders and so on
is going to require an international
effort it's not all going to be done
here and so Pat and Laurie with the help
of Hugo Xiang decided that they would
establish brain Institute's in China who
they felt we're going to be making a
major contribution to neuroscience in
the future and they established these
three McGovern institutes in Beijing who
are all represented here today and we'll
be hearing more from them and we've now
developed this Cooperative Research
Center in Shenzhen that's developing the
genetically altered primates for example
and and we've seen now this developing
of this international network for
neuroscience that I think is already
beginning
to pay off and neuroscience discoveries
that we'll be hearing today and I think
one of the things that's really
encouraging about the development of the
neuroscience of the Chinese Institutes
is that they're following this same
multidisciplinary concept that we're
applying here in other words they're
studying the mind and brain across
multiple levels of scale many people are
sitting at the intersections of
different techniques molecular learning
systems and so on and they're
establishing Institute's where people
can then talk all these across all these
levels and I think we have become
confident that these kinds of
interactions across people will enable
us to understand the interactions in the
brain and and now I would say Pat if
you've been listening I hope that you
accept this this progress that we've
been making from what you got started
you and Lori started here at the
McGovern Institute and that maybe you
would give us some encouragement in Glen
Rifkin describe the famous memos that
Pat gave at IDG the good news memo
telling people how wonderful things were
going and suggesting how they might make
it even more wonderful and I can imagine
if Pat were here now we would be getting
the equivalent and giving us
encouragement in the future as well so
thanks Pat and I will
[Applause]